landmark legal settlement involving a
drug company blamed for helping fuel the
opioid crisis is triggering a major
backlash Purdue Pharma the maker of
oxycontin agreed to pay 270 million
dollars to the state of Oklahoma the
settlement allows Purdue and its
controlling owners the Sackler family to
avoid a damaging trial and deny
wrongdoing that has angered people
personally affected by the opioid
epidemic tonita copal is outside the
Metropolitan Museum of Art in New York
where the Sackler zuv the major donors
Tony good morning good morning the
cyclers have given millions to major
institutions like this one all over the
world now as part of the settlement
they'll give 75 million to the state of
Oklahoma but a critics worry that any
settlement sets a dangerous precedent
for the 35 states and hundreds of cities
still suing the drug maker this begins a
new chapter for those struggling with
addiction Oklahoma Attorney General Mike
hunter declared Monday's settlement of
victory despite telling us last year he
planned to take the case all the way to
trial I have confidence in our laws I've
confidence in a jury of Oklahomans for
some people affected by the epidemic the
settlement felt like a setback this was
expected to be the first lawsuit of its
kind against Purdue Pharma to go to
trial and even be televised I almost
lost my life because of Purdue's greed
Ryan Hampton says his own addiction to
opioids started with a single
prescription for a leg injury in 2003
now in recovery he wants Purdue to face
its accusers publicly Purdue is being
spared being transparent and open and
that is exactly what needs to happen
more than 1500 additional cities and
states have filed similar and still
active lawsuits against Purdue alleging
that it aggressively marketed oxy cotton
and downplayed its dangers in some cases
members of the Sackler family which owns
the company are named as co-defendants
including a Massachusetts lawsuit
alleging the family has made more than 4
billion in profits since 2007 alone
270 million dollars that is pennies to
what we should have been getting a
majority of the settlement 200 million
will go to build a national center for
addiction studies and treatment at
Oklahoma State
University in Tulsa in a statement
current Purdue CEO Craig Landau calls
the Oklahoma settlement an extension of
our commitment to help drive solutions
to the opioid addiction crisis Ryan
Hampton sees a different path to justice
not only should we be getting tens of
billions of dollars and members of the
Sackler family should be sitting in jail
instead they are issuing statements the
families of Raymond and Mortimer Sackler
said that the settlement in Oklahoma is
unique and not a financial model for
future discussions the Matt meanwhile is
reviewing its gift policy in light of
the Sackler and John three other major
museums have already said they will no
longer accept Sackler money now Tony
thank you